hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
I'm here with row our pups today yeah we
could eat
we are unboxing a dog bed and I'm so
excited about this cuz it's basically a
dog bed for people that travel or go
places so I'm not really sure what its
gonna look like but okay it's a
Kickstarter from some people in
Pittsburgh and I'm originally from
Pittsburgh
so I'm more excited to test this out
because it is from my hometown I love
this I love dog gadgets new dog links to
this hashtag get your paws dirty oh my
gosh it does we're ready let's get our
paws dirty girl
let's open up this little dog bag and
see how it do I'm so excited about this
cuz we always travel and it's always
such a struggle trying to get like all
of his stuff together his beds
holes everytime towels our doggy
friendly I bring cookies doggy stroller
your dad you had all her treats yeah I
brought to New York I'm like oh I see a
handle Maddy must know this is for him
like he's getting really excited over
here is this for us
I don't look till you have something in
your eye I'll get it I'll go so mad like
they must have known that this was a dog
product because we didn't bring them
over here like they wanted to be here
for this I didn't jumped up with this I
had to pull up a chair because she
wanted to be here this is like a dog
suitcase ready yes alright so let's open
it up here oh okay
it's zip Sophie
what do you like this Wow okay they're
both so into it like how do they know
this is for them
Justine they're just gonna show it off
look at him go oh wow yes see what you
think cookie what do you think of it my
gosh Maddie's tail is wagging so hard
he's handsome bowtie I know he knew
usually gonna boxing so dapper today
cookie didn't wear her cute pink bow she
was a little route unruly this morning
look at this a cute little bandana okay
you are all about wow oh wow let's move
these out of the way like I love their
design everything hard do you think they
wrote Maddie a note I think it might
just be like for everybody like that's
just what they do many here okay cookie
well quickly go into everything all the
time
she this is her she just jumped into
stuff she loves it she is so into it
cookie isn't it a 4 out of 4 pause okay
definitely she is into it oh my gosh I
have to get her one of these just see
like Julie loves this I'm gonna have to
get one this is great but like you could
throw all of your stuff in here and then
you just take it with you it's like a
dog bed suitcase let's see what's the
note wow thanks it is a personalized
note hey Justine we're so excited to
share our bed with you and Maddie we
designed it to make traveling with our
pups painless and easy and we hope that
it does that for you guys
best Lia and Eli oh my gosh you guys
design I am such a huge fan of like well
don't why gosh oh he's so thoughtful and
even their Knoll is like totally
handwritten
lace is so hurts and lies incredible I
love this cookie cookie cookie cookie
you're gonna fall along okay this is so
cute
I am so amazing how did you want to get
up there and see I know
cookie come here okay maybe probably get
you a smaller bed let's put this on you
so you feel fancy yeah they have very
different size oh my gosh it's a nice
little leash that's really whoa spruce
pop calm get your paws dirty this is so
cool
usually you can wear it like a little
bandana skirt but also you can be a cute
little lady oh my gosh this all guys
look you nearly stickers and some of you
look at this I mean wow they have a lot
of accessories they've got hats and
little t-shirts I love that leash though
that's very nice I guess a cookie loves
his bed she just wants to be on she
really does cookie we can share I'll
bring it over every time I come over
they were really cool logo I really
loved a little spoon he's too cute that
it can you may sit your butt down this
is not a toy goody this is a leash so
professional would this is a
professional rock climbing rope and it
must be retired after a certain amount
of uses for safety and legal reasons so
instead of singing that rope go to a
landfill they're recycling it so this is
a recycled rope that's been lining up
this is actually so I'm so impressed
I'm loving this so much like I can't
even I can't even handle it
great idea this is absolutely nice leash
hey I'm loving the colors I'm loving
everything this is super cute I love it
it three different sizes I think this is
the medium there's a small and there's a
large it has pockets on the side that
you put little things in here like
little treats
that's so great oh okay want me to read
you the features yes okay let me read
you the features milady one waterproof
sheets
Oh case we have an accident - durable
materials
there's stash pockets that we found on
the side of these it has industrial
hardware at the top and stuff it is
industrial whoo girl this is what cookie
likes it's a 2 inch memory foam padding
that she loves that memory foam cookie
she is so fancy she that like if it's
memory foam she's on it I get so into
this like we can't even keep her off the
table no it's machine washable
that's weak J Lo's if it's not machine
washable for dog stuff I'm like no bye
damn look this just kind of comes off
it's like the velcro in there it has
padded handles tuck in bolsters and
fitted sheets so they're like little
sheets you can take them off and wash up
I love it so much what a great idea
oh this is so cool and in the picture
they pack in like their stuff in here
yeah yeah here oh come here kitty sue me
give me three sweet so baby put it back
on okay she loves it
look at that so you pack all your dog's
goodies in here close it up so it's the
bed and their suitcase I mean we can't
keep cooking off of it we travel a lot
we go up to like Big Bear to the
mountains and stuff yeah Maddy's just
trying to get away from cookie babies
like it's weird
he took my bed well this is really cool
let me know what you guys think in the
comments below if this is something that
you would use is this like perfect for
your dog cuz honestly this is so perfect
for somebody who travel
or even just like a great dog by the
fact it's impossible to are their size
they're just kind of like one size three
sizes so this is the medium size that
are small and then also a large for big
dogs I think it's you know yeah there's
like the big guy yeah there's the big
dog that's you know what this makes me
just want to get another dog cuz I feel
like we can fit two cookies on here
probably good man you can't just
throwing it out their mouth mr. husky
maybe I will like another dog oh my god
we need out there well this is great
I'll probably end up bringing this over
which I'm not bring Matty over now um
yeah could you will hate it if she's
clearly not in she's no he doesn't like
this at all
well thank you guys so much for watching
put a link in the description if you
wanna check this out go follow our dog
as we do run this cookie evidence where
she doesn't have anticipated I need to
get her one you let me know if you'd
like to see a cookie Instagram I've been
getting a lot of requests for it over
the years and I was always thinking like
oh she's not old enough she's only four
here on social media but I think now's
the time this is so cool it's so well
designed
I love thoughtful design I think it's
just so important and I think they
really did a great job with this I even
love the sheets have little like trees
and little dog foam designs on I know I
can even the sheet like the cushion
fabric designs really cute absolutely
matted you like it but did she take your
bed for you she did I know she really
did she'll have to give it back in sheer
but look at this cute little face look
at this happy pup everybody she's
already snoozing she's so excited on a
rotator look at her you believe it was
my bed it's okay Matty we share oh and
we should tell them to go we tested out
a bunch of dog gadgets this was like
last year sometime it so many gadgets so
many gadgets oh maybe you guys should go
check out that video if you haven't seen
it already it was so much fun
we need to do more you do follow up I
found some dog gadgets kitchen gadgets
as we can't even handle it okay we'll
see you later bye
[Music]